ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้สวัสดีครับน้องเรียน
สวัสดีครับนักเรียน
อ้าวกลับมาเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้แล้วก็นัก
เรียนในช่องเรียงอยู่ด้านไหนอยู่ด้านนี้
อาในช่องกรองเปลี่ยนสโมทัยนะครับโอเคนะ
ฮ่าๆๆเจ๊วันนี้วันนี้วันนี้เรามาเจอกันนะ
ครับวันนี้วันอะไรครับ 5 วันนี้วันอังคาร
ค่ะอ้าวันนี้วันอังคารพ่อวันนี้วันอังคาร
ใช่ไหมแล้วพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธใช่ไหมอ๋ออ๋อวันนี้วัน
อังคารพรุ่งนี้วันพุธแอร์แล้วเมื่อวาน
เมื่อวานวันอะไรครับเมื่อวานวันอาอ้า
เมื่อวานวันจันทร์โอเคอ้าวันนี้วันอังคาร
วันอังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันอังคารที่
10  54 ค่ะวันอังคารที่ 14 โอเควันนี้
วันอังคารที่ 14 พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันวัน
พุธเท่าไหร่ครับวันวันพุธ 7 ยี่ 5
55 ไส้ไหมครับ
เพราะฉะนั้นเมื่อวานเมื่อวานชี้ไปทางไหน
เนี่ยงงเมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันที่ไปครับ
เมื่อวานวันที่
13 เมื่อวานวันที่ 13 ไพร ka วันนี้วัน
อังคาร
ที่ 14  5  5 เดือนอะไรครับเดือนธันวาก็
คง 5 เดือนธันวาคม
เคเดือนธันวาคมแล้วปีคศอะไรครับข้อ 2 ต.ค
2010  21 ค่ะ 21 โอเคคศ 2000  21 วาว
แล้ว a  b ผชอะไรครับพ.ต.
2564 ค่ะ
2564 โอเค
เดือนธันวาคมอ้าวโอเคแล้ว 5 ตอนนี้อันนี้
เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันแล้วตอนนี้กี่โมง
แล้วครับตอนนี้
เฮ้ย
8:00 นตรงเลยค่ะมา 8:00 น
8:00 นตรงใช่ไหม 8 โมงตรงงาน 00 น 8:00
นโอเคเป็นสิ่งที่เรานอนใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะตอน
เช้าเราต้องยืนตรงนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้
8:00 น
8:00 นเราจะเปิดเปิดเพลงชาติใช่มั้ยเพลง
ชาติไทยอ่าเราก็จะยืนตรงยืนตรงยืนตรง
เคารพธงชาติประเทศทั้งเนื้อชาเชื้อตายให้
ราชา
5 ตอนเช้า 8:00 นด้วยครับ
8:00 นหมอแล้ววันนี้วันนี้เราจะมาคุยกัน
เรื่องเรื่อง
ธงชาติใช้ธงชาติตอน 8:00 นเดตอน 8:00 น
นักเรียนหรือว่าเทียบอี้อี้เรียนก็จะได้
ยินเสียงเพลงชาติเสียงเพลงชาติไทยฮะ
ประเทศไทยรวมเลือดเนื้อชาติเชื้อไทยเนื้อ
หาชายครับมีเสียงเองช่าตอน 8 โมง 6
ใช่ไหม
โอเคอ้านี่นี่เป็นธงชาติ
พงศ์ชาติหน้าธงชาติของของคนไทย 5 ของ
ประเทศไทยหน้ามีคงชาติ
ท้องนะถ้าของเรามีกี่สีคะพี่ปี้ของชาติ
ของเรามีกี่สีครับนี่ลงนี้ 1 นิ 2 ตรงนี้
3-5 มี 3-4 ครับอ้ามีสี
มีสีแดงนะครับอ้ะสีขาว
แล้วก็สีน้ำเงินอ้ามี 3 สีไหมครับตรงนี้
ก็เป็นสีขาวเหมือนกันสีแดงเหมือนหัวหน้า
แล้วก็มีสีน้ำเงินสีน้ำเงินอยู่ตรงปาง
เวลาคงปาง
แรงสีแดงอยู่ขอบขอบาชูขอบสองด้านใช่ไหม
ครับอ่ะขอบอ่า
ขอบสองด้านหน้าเป็นสีแดงไหมครับ
ใช่ค่ะค่ะมีสีขาวสีขาวก็อยู่ 2 ด้าน
เหมือนกันด้านนี้ได้อ้ะด้านนี้
ใช่ครับ
แล้วธงชาติไทย 3 สีนี้
มีความหมายไหมคะ
ธงชาติไทย 3 สีมีความหมายครับ
แล้วคับ eh อีกที่หนึ่งสีแดงสีแดงใช่ไหม
ครับสีแดงสีแดงหมายถึง
We  Are  Seen แดงสีแดงมีครับสีแดงสีแดง
หมายถึงอ่า
ประเทศไทยงูใช่ครับหมายถึงประเทศไทยนี่
ครับประเทศไทย
น้าเป็นประเทศไทย
10 แหกเอออันนี้คือประเทศไทยมีประเทศ
ประเทศไทย Thailand นะครับประเทศ
อเมริกาประเทศจีนประเทศ China
ประเทศ A  Friend นะครับอ่าเป็นประเทศแต่
นี้สีแดงอันนี้หมายถึงประเทศไทยไทยๆสีแดง
ที่อยู่บนธงชาติสีแดงที่อยู่บนธงชาติหมาย
ถึงประเทศไทยนะครับ
หมายถึงประเทศไทยเราก็จะเรียกสีแดงว่า
เป็นสีของประเทศออกไปหรือ
ชาติไทยตลาดได้ครับสีแดงคือชาติไทยอาแดง
คือชาติไทยนะครับ
โอเคแล้วก็
สีอะไรอีกค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้มีสีขาวอันนี้สี
ขาวสีขาวนี้อ้าหมายถึงอาหมายถึงศาสนา
ศาสนาคืออะไร
ศาสนาคืออย่างเช่นอ้ะศาสนาพุทธหน้าศาสนา
คริสต์นะครับอ่ามีศาสนาอะไรอีกครับอิสลาม
บูรณ์พุทธศาสนาคริสต์ศาสนาอิสลามมีศาสนา
อ่าฮินดูหากมีศาสนาอะไรดีครับซิใช่ไหม
ครับพุทธคริสต์อิสลามหนังสติ๊ก
ยิงลักษณาทุกศาสนาในประเทศไทยมีคนที่มีคน
ที่นับถือศาสนาหลายๆศาสนาขอพี่อาร์ตี้นับ
ถือศาสนาอะไรคะเฮียตี้นับถือศาสนาพุทธ
ครับศาสนาพุทธ 5 ซ้ายครับมีศาสนาพุทธหาก็
มีพระพุทธเจ้านะครับแล้วก็มีนี้เป็นศาสนา
พุทธอ่ะได้ค่ะแม่แล้วน้องเรียมน้องเรียม
นับถือศาสนาอะไรครับเตรียมนับถือศาสนา
พุทธค่ะอ้อศาสนาพุทธชายครับเพราะว่าคน
ส่วนใหญ่คนส่วนใหญ่ในประเทศไทยคนส่วนใหญ่
ในประเทศไทยก็จะนับถือศาสนาพุทธ
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้คือน่าจะเป็นศาสนาครุฑหน้า
เป็นรูป
พระ
มันไหม
อาหาๆได้ครับได้ครับ
ศาสนาพุทธก็จะเป็นรูปพาวงสัญลักษณ์ก็จะ
เป็นใส่ละเป็นวงกลมแบบนี้อ๋อแมนเป็นวงกลม
วงกลมมีทำมาจากอยู่ข้างในเราเรียกว่าทำมา
จากนายๆเป็นตัดสนา put  her  I  come มา
จากวาด
เสมือนล้อรถโอเคไปคืออันนี้มีทำมาจากมี
วงเวียนทำหรือทำมาจากใช่ค่ะนายคงจำได้ว่า
ทำมาจากนี้ก็คล้ายๆกับรอรถ
ใช่ครับทำมาจากล้อรถอ่ะ 5 ใช้ขับหมุนไป
หมุนไปอ่ะคุณแม่อันนี้เป็นศาสนาพุทธอาหาร
นอกจากมีคนนับถือศาสนาพุทธแล้วก็ยังมีคน
นับถือศาสนาคริสต์ในประเทศไทยด้วย
ก็มีคนที่นับถือศาสนาคริสต์นะครับเฮีย
ติ๊กคิดว่านักเรียนนักเรียนส่วนใหญ่อะที่
กำลังดูเบียร์ที่อยู่ก็น่าจะน่าจะรู้จัก
รู้จักแล้วก็อัดมีบางคนที่นับถือศาสนา
คริสต์ด้วยครับใช่ค่ะในประเทศไทยก็มีคน
ที่นับถือศาสนาคริสต์ใช่ขายอยู่เยอะมากๆ
นะคะมีเยอะเหมือนกันใช่ครับแล้วก็อ่ามีคน
ที่นับถือศาสนาคริสต์ในประเทศไทยแล้วก็มี
คนที่นับถือศาสนาอิสลามด้วย
ใช่ค่ะมีคนที่นับถือมีศาสนาอิสลามในครับ
โอเคเราก็จำไม่ได้ว่ากี่เปอร์เซ็นต์เพื่อ
ตีคอกให้รู้เหมือนกันได้ค่ะเฮียตีก็จำไม่
ได้นะครับหน้าโอเคแล้วก็อ่าเห็นอ่ะเมื่อ
กี้เมื่อกี้เราอยู่รูปไหนรูปนี้อ้าสีสี
แดงสีแดงหมายถึงชาติใช่ไหมครับหมายถึง
ประเทศไทย Thailand แล้วก็สีขาวสีขาวหมาย
ถึงศาสนาใช่ไหมทุกศาสนาเลยพุทธคริสต์
อิสลามอินดูซิอายอยู่ในสีขาวนี้อ่า
มีสีแดงชาติที่เค้าศาสนาแล้วสีน้ำเงินนะ
มีสีน้ำเงินด้วยนะครับสีน้ำที่เนินหมาย
ถึงอะไรคะปีกสีน้ำเงินหมายถึงอ้า
หมายถึงพระมหากษัตริย์
มีงามสะอาดนะครับพระมหากษัตริย์นี่นี่คือ
พระมหากษัตริย์นะครับหน้าพระมหากษัตริย์
หือว่าอาเป็นพระราชานั่นเองนะครับเป็น
King อาของของประเทศไทยทรายไทยก็จะเรียก
ว่าพระราชา
เรียกว่า
พระมหากษัตริย์
ชายได้ครับก็คืออยู่ในสีน้ำเงินอายุในธง
ชาติของไทย
ตอนนี้ที่ประเทศไทยมีพระมหากษัตริย์
กี่พระองค์แล้วคะที่ประเทศไทยมีพระ
มหากษัตริย์
r10 ตอนนี้มี 10 พระองค์แล้วท้ายครับ
หน้าสิบๆๆๆ
ฮะ
แล้วเวลาไปตอนนี้ 8:00 นใช่ไหมคะพี่เอา
ใช่ครับ 8 โมงผ่านมาแล้ว R ฮะแต่เวลา
8:00 น
ของทุกวัน 5 ทุกวันเลยตอนเช้าเช้าก็จะได้
ยินเสียงเพลงชาติชาติใช่ครับใช่ค่ะอัน
นั้นคิดใหญ่คะพี่อติอันนี้รู้นี้เป็นที่
โรงเรียนครับที่โรงเรียนน่ะเป็นตอน 8 โมง
เช้าเหมือนกัน
8:00 นก็จะมีเสียงเพลงชาติ
หน้ามีเพลงชาติหน้าที่ที่โรงเรียนใช่ครับ
มีเพลงชาติและทุกคนเวลาที่ได้ยินเพลงชาติ
ทุกคนเป็นไงครับอ่ะ
ก็อาจมันก็ยืนทองอายุยืนตรงเคารพธงชาติ
อ่ะไม่ไม่เฉพาะที่โรงเรียนข้างนอกที่อื่น
ในตลาดในบนถนนนะครับเวลาคนเดินเดินๆแล้ว
ได้ยินได้ยินเพลงชาติประเทศไทยรวมทุกคนก็
จะยืนตรงเกิดหนึ่งตรงเคารพธงชาติจ้าๆค่ะ
เหมือนเรียมเตรียมไปที่ตลาดน้าครับยังไป
ที่ตลาด
ไปซื้อของเอาลายใส่จ่ายเงินซื้อของขับ
เอ็มก็ได้ยินเสียงเพลงชาติอ้าวน้องเรียน
ทำยังไงครับพี่อะไรได้ยินเลยเดินแล้วได้
ยินเสียงเพลงชาติลืมก็หยุด
5 ตรงฮ่าฟังเพลงชาติ
ยืนตรงเคารพธงจ้าาและเคารพธงชาติรบธงชาติ
ได้ครับคอร์ดประเทศไทยร่วมเงินเนื้อชาติ
เชื้อไทยจนจบจบแล้วเรียนก็ไงใส่โยเกิร์ต
ต่อ
หาใส่เขาใช้ครับแล้วทุกๆคนนะครับวันนั้น
ที่เรียมไป
ตลาดนะคะหน้า
ตลาดทุกๆคน
คนเยอะๆเลยอ่าใช้ครับทุกๆคนถ้าเป็นถ้า
เป็นคนไทยคนไทยคนไทยก็จะหยุดอยู่ตรงใช่
มั้ยใช่
เกิดมีคนเยอะๆก็จะยืนตรงไปครับ
ใช่ค่ะ
บางคนแล้วนั่งอยู่เตรียมเห็นนั่งอยู่
ท่านั่งอยู่นั่งอยู่ทำยังไงครับก็จะยืน
ขึ้นฮ่าๆเอาแต่นั่งอยู่กันลุกขึ้นยืนใต้
รูปขึ้นยืนได้ยินดียังเพลงชาติก็จะลุก
ขึ้นยืนตรง
ใช่ครับ 5 บางคนบางคน
บางคน
คนที่ไม่ใช่คนไทยไม่ใช่คนไทยมาเห็นคนไทย
ยิมจงงงงงเซลล์ 2 มาช่องใครอีกนึง
รู้สึก
งงได้เอาหยุดทำไม
ได้ฮะ
โอเคเรายืนตรงเคารพธงชาติธงชาติตอนไหน
บ้างครับ
มีตอน
8:00 น 8:00 นตอน 8 โมงเช้าเนี่ยตอน 8
โมงเช้าเรา We  Are
ชาร์จทองชักธงขึ้นไปขึ้นไปบนเสาใช่ไหม
8:00 นใช่ค่ะอ้าแล้วก็ตอนเย็นด้วยตอน
เย็นน่ะตอนนี้ตอนเช้าใช่ไหมครับ 08:00 น
แต่ตอนเย็นตอนเย็นที่ผ้าทิพย์พระอาทิตย์
ตกลงมาแล้วเราเอาธงลง
ใช่ค่ะเราเรียกว่าอะไรนะคะพี่
ทักธงหรอชาร์จธงได้เอาซักองค์ขึ้นไปใช่
ชักธงเข้าไป
มันจะมีเสาใช่ไหมคะพี่ถ้ามีสาวใช้งานวัน
นี้เสาธง
ใช่เราก็จะมีเชือก
เราว่าคน
ก็ดึงเชือกได้ครับหน้าเราคงคิดว่าชักธงนะ
คะชาติก็จะขึ้นขึ้นไปเรื่อยๆ
ทรายวันนี้
ใช่ครับใช่ค่ะตอน 8:00 นใช่ไหมคะพี่
อาร์ตี้
8:00 นหาธงชาติก็จะขึ้นชักธงชาติขึ้นไป
ข้างบนอา
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เตรียมได้ยินเสียงเพลงชาติตอน 18:00
นด้วยนะคะพี่อาร์ตี้มาใช่ครับตอนเย็นด้วย
ตอนเย็นก็คือเอ่อเท่าไหร่ครับ
18 ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
15 เราเรียก 18 หรือว่าเป็น 6  6  PM มา
แต่ถ้าเป็น 6  PM ใช่ค่ะเย็น 18:00 นเรา
ก็
ชาร์จธงลง
น้ำได้ครับเย็นก็จะไม่
ชักคงลงจะมีคนนะคะมีคนดึง
ก็มีเพลงชาติอีกเหมือนกันมีเพลงชาติตอน
เย็นอีกเหมือนกันแล้วทุกคนพอได้ยินเพลง
ถ้าทุกคนก็ยืนตรงเหมือนกันเหมือนเดิมใจ
กับเหมือนตอนเช้านะ
ๆให้ตอนเช้า
1 วันเหมือนวันนี้เป็นวันที่
14 ใช่ไหมคะได้เขาวันนี้วันอังคาร 24
ตอนเช้าตอนนี้ตอนนี้ 8 โมงตอนนี้ 8:00 น
เมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้
เราก็ได้ยินเพจเพลงชาติแล้ว 1 ครั้ง
แล้วตอน 6 ช่วงเย็นเราจะได้ยินเพชรเพลง
ชาติอีก 1  3 ๆทรายหาก
ในวันนี้เราก็จะได้ยินเสียงเพลงชาติกี่
ครั้งค่ะพี่สองครั้งครับมีตอนเช้า
อ่อนเย็นตอนเช้าธงขึ้นตอนเย็นธงลงชาย
แล้วเราก็จะต้องยืนตรง
ยืนตรงเคารพธงชาติ
วันนี้เหมือนกัน
ใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
ถ้าถ้าไม่ได้ยิน
ถ้าไม่ได้ยินทำไม่ได้ยินเราเข้าไม่ยืนไม่
ยืนใช่ไหมไม่ยืนเอาไม่ได้ยินไม่ได้ยินไม่
เป็นไรไอ้เขาใส่ครับ
[เพลง]
น้าโอเคทีนักเรียนพ่อหน้ากากแล้วว่าธง
ชาตินะครับธงชาติของไทยนะครับมีอ่ะ 3 สี
ใช่ไหม 3 สีแดงสีขาวสีน้ำเงินอ้ะสีแดง
หมายถึงชาติไทยล่ะประเทศไทยใช่อ่ะสิหาว
หมายถึงศาสนานะครับคนไทยนับถือ Case เจอ
Please
อิสลามฮินดูซิกอาจได้หมดทุกศาสนาในประเทศ
ไทยมีทุกศาสนานะครับหมายถึงสีขาวนะครับ
ใช้หาแล้วก็สีน้ำเงินนะครับสีน้ำเงินหมาย
ถึงพระมหากษัตริย์และมันจริงๆทรายครับ
โอเคแล้วก็นี่ก็คืออ่าธงชาติที่เราได้
เรียนรู้กันในวันนี้นะครับอ่ะโอเคแล้ว
เบี้ยนนักเรียนอย่าลืมยืนตรงอยู่ตรงเวลา
ได้ยินเพลงชาติไทยนะครับฮ่าๆเวลานักเรียน
เดินเดินไปและนักเรียนจะได้รู้ว่าอ๋อมีมา
เพลงแล้วทำไมคนไทยเดินไปแล้วหยุด
ใช้ครับดูนะคะหน้าแสดงว่าเป็นมีเพลงชาติ
ใช่ๆคนไทยก็จะยืนตรงเคารพธงไม่ได้
โอเคแล้ววันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวคราวหน้ากลับมานะครับกลับมา
เรียนภาษาไทยกับพี่อาตีกับน้องเรียมใน
ช่องคอมเพรนสเบอร์ไทยกันใหม่นะครับ 5 วัน
นี้พี่ลาไปก่อนครับน่ะสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีกว่าเฮียตี้โรงเรียนบ๊ายบายนัก
เรียนได้บ้างไปชม